so i'm watching the national
championship semifinal games and i'm
like just how good can these guys
possibly be
they look pretty damn good amazing and i
said we got to get this guy on to talk
about how good they can possibly be
let's start evaluating and then
everything else starts blowing up in the
nfl world as well
my buddy from nfl network at move the
sticks also the move the sticks podcast
with him and bucky brooks
he is jeremiah back here in the
richardson show happy new year dj
happy new year rich how's it going we're
hanging in there man we are hanging in
there
um out if you heard uh here on the show
all year long i was hoping the jets
would keep losing dj
oh i'm sorry you keep texting you text
me you text me you text me every single
quarter the jets
uh look pretty good uh so uh at any rate
so let's talk about the evaluation of
the quarterbacks from this past weekend
uh and i will give you the floor on what
we should glean
from uh uh trevor lawrence and justin
fields on the same field
that tape that i'm sure will be bandied
about quite a bit over the next several
weeks leading up to the draft
what do you guys think yeah i i think
that i think look
football some things are consistent
through all levels of football through
all of time and that is
that if you're better in the trenches
you have a good chance of winning and i
think when you come out of that game we
get to the quarterbacks but i thought
ohio state was so
far superior to clemson and the trenches
and they did a better job of protecting
justin fields
uh then clemson did of protecting trevor
lawrence it is
by far the best i've ever seen justin
fields play
um and you add on to that the toughness
that he displayed which was
you know incredible um to have that
performance on that stage and it's worth
more
than than uh than just having a good
game in a regular season game i mean
that's going to really help him in the
evaluation
but i didn't see anything that game that
would detract me or discourage me about
trevor lawrence still being the
the top guy i think he will be the first
overall pick in jacksonville
i think they'll feel they'll feel good
about that but uh i i think justin
fields who going into that game rich
from what i've seen these guys and again
a long way to go my first list comes out
the 18th
um but you know from where i had these
quarterbacks kind of coming into this
game
i had zach wilson as the number two and
i had justin fields
and trey lance kind of battling it out
for that number three spot and then all
of a sudden
justin fields goes from the previous
three games four touchdowns five picks
11 sacks
not playing great to putting on a com
you know just an absolute show against
clemson now he does that against alabama
nick saban
on the next in the next one uh that that
changes some things
so with all that in mind uh
dj we we know jacksonville at one is
gonna take a quarterback and it's gonna
he's
they're gonna take the quarterback uh
trevor lawrence
that said the jets now have a decision
whereas
no-brainer if it was trevor lawrence
they still do have
sam darnold in their midst and now a ton
of tape albeit with
uh a a lot of shall we call them
variables from coach to scheme to
players and things of that
nature what do you think the decision is
for joe douglas at two
going to be darnold versus every other
name that you mentioned minus trevor
lawrence
walk me through that evaluation if you
don't mind
well i'll start with how about this for
an interesting weekend if you're joe
douglas
you can spend uh the weekend in the nfl
watching a former adam gates quarterback
you know potentially lead his team on a
deep postseason run
and look like a different player than
what he was under adam gates you can
spend one day doing that then you can
turn around and watch justin fields
and try and evaluate him versus uh
you know versus sam darnold versus zach
wilson you know
there's a lot to compute here uh for the
jets and a lot of different ways they
can go
um to me i think what makes the most
sense to me individually and
this has nothing to do with you know
what the jets will do in their decision
but me
personally rich i just like a fresh
start i like you're going to hire a new
coach
you get a chance to bring in the new
quarterback and the clock starts now
and off you go and that to me would be
trying to evaluate the difference
between zach wilson
and justin fields and you could say oh
we could trade back and get other picks
don't mess around with the quarterback
if if that's the one that you like
you know right behind trevor lawrence
and he's the best guy take him don't get
cute
well they do have a second first round
selection because of the jamal adams
trade we don't know where that's going
to land
um so in the 20s mid to late 20s
right probably at best right exactly um
so let's just let's just put it this way
then
uh who would be the non-quarterback that
would maybe be the bright shiny object
uh for uh joe douglas in the same way
that you know
you see what chase young and nick bose
have been for
their teams second overall is there
somebody like that
in this draft that's flashing on the
screen on the past weekend
maybe or no i i don't i don't i think
there's
some really good receivers that are
going to be up there i don't
for me personally penne sewell is not my
top rated tackle so i know
some people have talked about him being
worth that pick that's too rich for me
um i like rashaan slater better than him
the tackle at northwestern so
um and i think it's a little bit early
for for those guys so i don't see the
offensive tackle there you just took
back them so you're good on the left
side
i don't see a pass rusher that's uh
that's worth that that pick
that high either i think the best
players once you kind of
you know evaluate the quarterbacks you
start looking at the the titan from
florida kyle pitts who's an
absolute freak which is going to be a
good discussion for us to have as we get
to the combine and get to the draft
because i believe
the number six overall is the highest
the tight end has ever been picked
which is like vernon davis and kellen
winslow jr
so you don't typically take tight end
all the way up there
but man i look at the chiefs who have
the best offense in football and their
offense runs through their tight end i
look at the patriots who had a dynasty
with an offense that ran through a tight
end
you could do a lot worse than kyle pitts
and then you start looking at devonta
smith
jamar chase would be there i mean those
are kind of skill guys but
you know no that's why to me it makes
the most sense just to find the
quarterback you love and take him there
too daniel jeremiah here on the rich
eisen show the best
uh player football player okay i mean
you could say trevor lawrence but if
if it is that then then give me number
two that we saw on the field this past
weekend
who's the best player give me that i
mean you know you know
to me it would actually justin fields
had the best performance of anybody on
the weekend right
i mean that's plain and simple that was
that was there for everybody to see the
best performance
well i'll tell you what uh j harris
pretty good pretty pretty good from
alabama
i know it's running backs and everyone
loves to hate on running backs but uh
man he is ready for the nfl he reminds
me people always look for for comps
right
he's not as he's not quite as fast as
matt forte
but man you remember 4k catching like
100 balls and was
big 6-2 225 230 pounds and
he was a great player that's who naji
harris reminds me of well alabama's tail
back you know right i mean derek henry
just ran for 2
000 yards you know we could keep going
ingram won a
heisman trophy there you could see
damian harris you could see josh
jacobs in the nfl right now uh
obviously uh you know um
uh kenyan drake my word why wouldn't you
now evaluate naji harris even better
than you normally would
right i mean yeah no that definitely
that definitely helps when you look at
the production those guys have had
and then the receiver wise i went back
and watched waddle i know there's some
talk that he might actually come back
and play in this championship game which
is crazy right rich he is unbelievable
like devonta smith's gonna win the
heisman trophy
and if if waddle plays the whole season
i'm not sure that he's
got the second best receiver on the team
that's how good he is so i mean that's
it's just nuts
uh what they've been able to do to
recruit and develop guys at alabama it
just it doesn't look fair
i i talked to damien square the other
day um who was with the chargers and he
was on their team that beat notre dame
in 2012 in the championship game and i
said
damian what do you remember about that
game because they were getting ready to
play notre dame again
and he said well we were late coming out
of the locker room and notre dame was in
the tunnel and so we ended up in the
tunnel right next to him
and so we're staring at notre dame
i go what do you mean he goes it looked
like notre dame looked like the kid that
knew they were going to have to fight
the school bully after school and it was
currently 8th period
and there are only eight periods in the
deck right that's what we're saying yeah
that that bill that bill was coming due
real quick
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show do you have a vote for the heisman
or or you do not
always on the rich eyes okay very good
so then i'm giving it to you i'm giving
it is it is smith you would that's who
you would choose i know you just said
that
he's going to win it but that would be
your choice amongst the four finalists
for the heisman he's been the most
dominant consistently dominant player in
college football
yeah absolutely man it's just amazing
what alabama is able to do year in and
year out so how do you think the
national championship game can play out
though
i watched i went back and watched some
more of field because i was like man i
got it just
you know i got to go back and look at
more him and so one of the one of the
issues was all these sacks that he took
so i went back and started just watched
all of his sacks and man rich a lot of
them were just
kind of busts up front where four man
rushes five man rushes
they were able to kind of confuse that
alabama front clemson wasn't able to do
that they weren't able to get home
there's a whole other story with what
went on in that game where
clemson you know people talk about them
stealing signals and all that kind of
stuff well if you look at that game
they would get the signal between the
time they got the signal and the snap
was just a couple seconds i mean
ohio state was ready they got the signal
got the snap off there are so many plays
in that game clemson didn't even set
defensively their defensive linemen are
standing up well alabama's not going to
have that problem and i think alabama's
going to be able to get home and get
some pressure on him so
i think alabama's offense and nick saban
i'll go with alabama on that one daniel
jeremiah here
on the rich eisen show let's talk about
uh the chargers
uh you call radio games with matt money
smith uh here locally in southern
california you do the chargers games
uh let's just start with anthony lynn
what what do you
why did why did they part ways with
anthony lynn best you can tell
well i think there was a number and i
don't have the number off top my head
but i want to say
something like 16 um you know one
possession losses over the last two
years
and you know some of it was uh
you know just kind of mismanagement of
some situations and and that you know
it kind of is what it is he's he is a
great man who is highly respected not
only in that building but around the nfl
uh for his leadership and and who he is
as a guy uh
tremendous but they that was a team that
just
lost too many too many games where you
could point to it you know some
decisions
here or there that didn't work out so i
i think that's what kind of led to
to where you know they ended up making a
change but the interesting thing is i i
think he'll
you know i think he'll get another
opportunity if it's not in this cycle
then
then going forward he'll get another
look i really believe that
um and then i look at the charger
situation is that job i don't know that
there's uh
anything close to it i know jacksonville
has all the picks and can get trevor
lawrence and the money
i know the jets we've talked about that
i think that's there's a lot of upside
there to that job
but we we think trevor lawrence is going
to be really good we feel
you know 95 on that one we've seen
justin herbert dominate at the nfl level
that's a known so that to me makes that
jump right to the front of the line yeah
bruce feldman um
our our colleague from fox sports and uh
the athletic he was on the show
yesterday he just tweeted out within 20
minutes ago that the chargers are
jumping in the urban meyer uh door knock
uh that basically they probably you just
gave the pitch right there is like yes
you
you got 100 million dollars in cap space
potentially
uh in jacksonville and trevor lawrence
and you can choose
your general manager or you can come to
los angeles tom telesco
is a guy who is a known professional
grocery shopper
and herbert is clearly a guy who we
already have seen
can succeed in the pros do you think
urban you know
obviously the college and professional
world do you think somebody who lost
only 15 times in his six years in
uh florida and only nine times in his
tenure at ohio state
could take all the losing that would
come
in the nfl even for a team that's a
playoff team
do you think he how do you think that
would work dj
well i don't think he could go to a
place where he couldn't win
so i i just i look at to me i can speak
to the to the charter's job just having
been around this team so much rich and i
look at
joey bosa who urban meyer obviously
knows very well
and i look at the second level of that
defense with kenneth murray drew
tranquil coming back i look at derwin
james coming back healthy
you've got premier players all three
levels of your defense you've got keenan
allen you've got hunter henry you've got
austin eckler you've got a stud
quarterback like i if urban meyer has
done nothing but win his whole life
he's not going to take a job where he
doesn't think he can win
and i think he could walk into that
chargers job and they could be an 11 or
12 win team next year and it wouldn't
surprise me in the least
okay so before i let you go what is the
scuttlebutt amongst the
uh talent evaluation and scouting
community which may be the chattiest
bunch of all the chatty bunches in the
nfl
about what happened on sunday night
football about what the eagles did
what what are you hearing ear to the
ground dan oh
i just i think that
the execution was very poor so
if you if you come into that game and
say
look nate slept's been here for four
years we want to evaluate some players
on our roster and so we're going to
start nate sutfeld in this game so we
can get a look at him
and i don't think it would have been
really much of a story the giants would
have been pissed
but it would have it wouldn't have been
a big stink it was okay they want to use
this opportunity to evaluate some young
players that's not new
that's been done a million times before
um but
the the time in which you decided to
insert subfelt into the lineup
on the heels of not taking a tying field
goal it just was it didn't look good man
i i look at it as a is uh you know if
you were
if you were a big time band and and you
had an opportunity to help a young
artist and you said hey we're going to
have you come out kind of warm the crowd
up a little bit before we get to our
opening act and then before i come on
the stage
but they like turned the lights down it
was go time and they they brought that
guy out as the lead singer like that
wasn't his time
you know and i guess again uh and that's
why i would love to get
more of the perspective of of the
scouting community um
and and the talent evaluation community
because all of that was sacrificed on
the altar of a better draft position
from what from what it really looks like
to me and look when you look back
when you look back on it and if they if
they get jamar chase with the sixth pick
and he wouldn't have been available at
the ninth pick for all the
four headlines and the grief and the
talk radio and all that stuff they're
not gonna care they got the better
players
i mean chris you you went down the sixth
overall picks right quentin nelson
jamal adams right yeah yeah jamal adams
and some great
great players we're just talking about
and justin herbert so
so i i understand that but then there is
also the evaluation of what goes on in a
locker room and these guys have got to
be
beyond pissed off and that's what i'm
saying
there's there's no reason why you can't
have your cake and eat it too
you could have you could have gone about
it and you know for
lack of a better word tanked the right
way which is just to start
him as opposed to trying to enter him
into the lineup at the end of the game
like that just
that didn't look good you could
accomplish both goals no and i know that
and
i'll reveal a little bit of our again
text exchanges that i have because i was
constantly texting you i'm like
can't the jets just lose every last game
and you're like you can't
you can't run a team in a locker room
like that i mean you were
you're kind of keeping me you know on
the road with some
you know sensible guardrails of me just
losing my mind while texting you
you know that you're basically that that
you can't do that in the nfl and i'm
like well why not
we're seeing it kind of all play out in
one microcosm
daniel yeah and it sounds like there's a
lot of frustration
um not just from uh from players but
other coaches
and the jets thing was interesting rich
because
you have like say the jets had done that
right say they had just pulled everybody
after they
after this the crazy game against the
raiders um
well then you the the worry is man is
this going to be
you you know a new coach would be
excited about coming in for trevor
lawrence but is the new coach going to
think that he's going to have to take
orders from management and the owner of
things like that it just kind of it
muddies the water a little bit
um so it's not apples to oranges the jet
situation versus the eagles situation i
think you could defend it more if the
jets had done it
this one was just again it was there's a
right way or wrong way to get to the
to get to the goal to get it
accomplished that was just the wrong way
to get there
dj happy new year thanks for the time uh
everyone check out daniel's uh podcast
with
bucky brooks uh move the sticks at move
the sticks on
uh twitter and instagram as well you're
the man thanks again for the call
dj appreciate you buddy it's nice to see
del tufa actually show up to work this
time usually
by the way again he's not wrong that
look that you you understand mike
you know you learned it with mayok as
well that everything's an evaluation
when you have a top-notch evaluator on
the program that's true i don't want dj
to copy your head on the switch
that's a red flag right daniel it's a
red flag i mean look
durability availability that matters oh
this is why we reached out to him uh
when we had that crucial uh
issue of of evaluating film
football players absolutely and that's
the reason why that's one of the most
popular youtube videos of 2020.
[Laughter]
you're the man dj thanks for the call
hey buddy good to see you guys happy new
year